you fool are an extrovert i know this
about you i've i've i've been on tour
with you
i went to germany to berlin with you on
a trip we've had many adventures
together
and i've seen you you need people around
you all the time you love the laughter
you love the connection how did you
survive during this period yes conan
it's more important for me to see lots
of eyeballs
and so when i realized i was just going
to be in my little apartamento
i decided to draw lots of faces
everywhere and i also i ordered
a photo of a sixth man of the year and
former indiana pacer deadlift shrimp
i laminated this and put this in my
shower so that while i'm loofaring we
can have a conversation about sam
perkins
okay so this former
nba great has been laminated into your
showers is that right deadlift shrimp
yes
say to him one more time okay you can
slow it down just a little bit sorry
yes of course
[Laughter]
i'm aware that during the pandemic you
tried to
um you don't have to match my mouth
you're trying to just you're wearing
very tight pants it's very tight across
your legs
so zero breathability yes um you
i'm aware that during this uh quarantine
and during the pandemic of the last 14
months that you have tried to send
something to my house
but i don't know what it was and uh i'm
not sure i received it
well it's a little bit awkward um as you
know i am german all of my family is in
germany and then the borders was bling
blank bloom no one inside you know so
i was like who can be my family in
america i thought of course
conan yes you know we are i like to
think of myself as
as a kin to you as a friend as family
yes yes yes yes like that highway to
heaven like i'm the man with the beard
and you are the man
uh who is having the wings you know uh
the tv show highway to heaven perhaps
you're right you're you're confused by
your own references yes i've already
forgotten uh what i just said yeah
however i was delivering every monday to
you
a nice tin of lee kuhn with all they
were bribery cookies if i want to be
honest
i wanted you to receive them and then
open them and see you know it was
adoption papers so that
we could you know hang hanging oh oh you
wanted me to adopt you
yes so you would send adoption papers to
my home or try
to yes very hard to get to my actual
home i know i'm an important man
and so my uh my address is a mystery 321
north mulberry avenue
thanks a lot beep it beep it no we can't
afford beeping oh yeah jeff said before
the show
no beefing yeah yeah all that money went
to the writers
yeah i get it i get it so um that's
staying in by the way
uh listen um you sent me a so
it was a cookies cookies what kind of
cookies
german tasty label yeah i sent you 15
one every monday and they never arrived
to you i know this because i was also
the courier i don't know if you remember
i was outside waving and then i could i
see
you i thought i saw you on the security
camera well i saw your face in the porch
you're just like
well i saw it no i didn't know it was
you i saw a man wearing lederhosen and a
bikini bottom
and i didn't know if i should let him in
so i didn't well that was me number one
and number two i have saved the final uh
can
this is from last april 15 and so i
would
like to officially i mean thank you very
much it has set it a bit but you can
so these are what they were last march
but oh oh these are these cookies have
crumbled
yeah that's how it happens with a cookie
this looks like
very well versed in our culture probably
not safe to eat this you can mumble all
you want
yes okay um anyway and this is the
adoption paper that you
yeah oh this is very unprofessional no
it's official
conan o'brien would you adopt fluliborg
now check
box please yes ja
now i think yes and ja are both yes
well yeah means yes yes
do you have an option was i do i have an
option to write in no
no okay all right well let me think
about this okay
i'm going to go through this with my
lawyers perfect and then say no
okay that's pretty much the order that's
going to happen it seems rude i
purchased a mobile for my baby room
you're going to want to live in a baby
room in my house well we have to begin
at the beginning have you seen the
madison billy show with adam sandley
where he starts small and then gets big
do you even know what you're saying the
madison billy show it's been many months
since i've made direct eye contact with
someone others than deadlift shrimp
while you're loofing in the shower you
know it have you been watching
no you told me that earlier oh that's
correct